it is my pleasure to introduce our
luncheon speaker
Theodore Malik has extensive experience
in both world monetary systems and
international governmental policy he
served on the Executive Board of the
World Economic Forum which hosts the
Davos meeting annually in Switzerland he
held an ambassadorial level position for
the United Nations in Geneva Switzerland
and he headed consulting at Porton chase
econometrics he has worked in
international capital markets at Salomon
Brothers and has served in senior policy
positions at the US Senate Committee on
Foreign Relations and in the US State
Department he is currently a research
professor for the spiritual capital
initiative at Yale University dr. Malak
earned his PhD in international
political economy from the University of
Toronto and he took a masters of
literature degree from Aberdeen
University in Scotland and a BA from
Gordon College in Massachusetts so he is
certainly well travelled with his
education he is here today to speak on
the subject of America's spiritual
capital which is the title of his latest
book co-authored with Nicholas Capaldi
please welcome dr. Theodore Malik
Thank You Andy I need to thank Hillsdale
College for putting together such a
brilliant forum certainly our friends at
the Council of Christian colleges and
universities and in particular I'd like
to thank my former student
Ranma Kirin who's here today and has
been your interlocutor on putting that
together and then I want to single out
for special attention over here at our
first table Nick Capaldi my co-author of
this little book America's spiritual
capital
Nik Nik is I think the most important
Catholic philosopher in America today
and I'm very pleased to have had the
chance not only to interact him with him
on this book but over a lifetime of
experiences at Liberty fund and
elsewhere now if there's anything at all
you like about our argument I will
accept all the praise and if there is
something that you dislike which is
remotely possible or with which you
might want to take issue I really want
to offer up Nick as someone who you can
blame now you might know as well and
need to mention this that I am the
product of one of your colleges Gordon
College even though today I'm doing
missionary work at Yale University
so here's the speech
America is a market-oriented
center-right polity and the modern
exemplar of the judeo-christian heritage
of spiritual capital let me present two
theses in this regard and demonstrate
what they mean for governing and markets
which is after all the theme of your
forum the first thesis concerns the
logic of modernity what distinguishes
modernity is the technological project
the transformation of nature for human
betterment as opposed to fatalistic
conformity the technological project
requires inner-directed
individuals and free market economies
that maximize competition and innovation
free market economies operate best with
limited government
Montesquieu's commercial republic and
Madison's Federalist number 10 limited
government can only be maintained under
the rule of law the rule of law can only
be sustained if there is a larger
cultural context that celebrates
responsible individual autonomy finally
responsible individual autonomy
presupposes a larger ontological claim
about human freedom or free will that
requires a theology
moreover personal autonomy avoids
self-destruction and adds a spiritual
content to the technological project
itself when the responsible use of
freedom leads to fulfilling or helping
to fulfil God's plan by eliminating
suffering and promoting freedom in and
for others now recognizing pursuing and
sustaining autonomy are the spiritual
quests of modernity and the
technological project which I believe is
best evidenced in the American
experiment to discover that
greatest sense of fulfillment comes from
freely imposing order on ourselves in
order to impose a creative order on the
world is perhaps the closest way of
coming to know God three considerations
lead us to maintain that responsible
personal autonomy requires theological
support first personal autonomy
presupposes free will this amounts to
saying that there is no naturalistic or
scientific explanation of the ultimate
truths about who we are
second we understand ourselves as
historical beings but history does not
form a self explanatory system our
interpretation of the whole human drama
depends on an intimately personal
decision concerning the part we are
meant to play in it in the end this is a
religious decision not a scientific or a
scholarly one finally sustaining our
autonomy under trying circumstances
requires spiritual stamina
since naturalism and scientism fail
theology and some important sense
emerges as the only discipline that can
provide ultimate comprehension the
second thesis is the documented history
of how settlers mostly religious
immigrants to these United States my
family and your families brought this
larger view to America nourished it and
sustained it at least up until now the
most important historical development in
the last four hundred years has been the
rise of the technological project this
project not the market is the starting
point of our narrative because although
there have always been markets it is
only since the 17th century that markets
have come to play such a dominant role
in our lie
it is the presence of the technological
project that explains the centrality of
markets the following claims with regard
to the technological project can be made
first it is an irreversible historical
fact abandonment of the project would
have catastrophic consequences for
Humanity and threaten our very existence
second to the extent that the project
creates environmental or other kinds of
problems and I met it does on occasion
we are now irrevocably committed to
using future developments in that
project to address and hopefully solve
those problems
third those cultures and we talked about
this a little bit this morning which
have most fully embraced the
technological project I would include
amongst them military technologies have
come to dominate the world and to spread
the technological project the spread has
not been a matter of the powerful
imposing on the weak the weak have
largely come to embrace the project on
their own the thorny issues of
globalization would not have developed
outside the context of the technological
project let's look at it again taking a
long view starting with Copernicus
Western thinkers became aware of how
much of what we understand reflects the
human perspective as did the artists
themselves in the Renaissance
Copernicus for example maintained that
despite appearances the Sun does not
rise and set rather the earth turns on
its axis starting with Copernicus and
reinforced by the works of Galileo
Descartes Newton and others Western
thinkers came to recognize how much of
science depended not on naive
observation of surface phenomenon but on
the construction of hypothetical even
mathematical models about hidden
structure Newton and Leibnitz would go
on later to invent calculus meaning and
structure in a word truths were
to be found externally but in the
internal models of the human mind wisdom
and success were transformed from canta
conformity to an external structure to
heading or conforming the external
physical world to human reason and
imagination the belief that human beings
could understand and control the hidden
structure of nature and that the hidden
structure was conducive to human benefit
was largely inspired by Christianity
among the first to proclaim the
technological project as a
self-conscious undertaking was Francis
Bacon when he proclaimed that knowledge
is power and Rene Descartes the French
philosopher mathematician physicist who
advocated that human beings make
themselves the Masters and possessors of
nature it is worth noting that Descartes
specifically singled out the importance
of advances in medical science for an
age in which the normal human lifespan
was just 36 years
it was also Descartes who in his
discourse on method advocated the
development of inner directed
individuals cooperating I underlined the
word cooperating father spoke about that
last night to produce innovative ideas
for understanding and controlling
natural processes finally Descartes who
also recognized how commercial
Republic's like Holland in the 17th
century were particularly hospitable to
these new developments they were
traitors the technological project is
fostered by an environment in which
human beings are given as much free
reign as possible to use their
imagination to think scientifically and
to develop new ways and products for
Humanity controlling the physical
environment to protect and heal the
human body and to make life more
comfortable and to make life more
enjoyable the economic institution most
conductive to this was the free market
economy
a system for the exchange of goods and
services wherein there is no central
allocation of such goods and services
the market economy was not itself
entirely new in fact it could be
maintained that private property had
always existed in historical memory the
church moreover had officially defended
the importance of private property what
was new was the recognition of how
crucial private property and a free
market economy were to the technological
project why is that innovation cannot by
definition be planned to the extent that
property is privately owned and not
centrally controlled and to the extent
that a free market economy is
competitive there is a greater
possibility for innovation we all know
this in his canonical work which marked
the beginning of modern economics Adam
Smith argued in The Wealth of Nations
1776 that a free market economy
encourages innovation it was innovative
because the division of labor led to the
specialization and specialization ledge
innovation as well as greater
productivity Smith's example you'll
recall it many in this room will the
manufacturing of pins explains how an
assembly line of narrowly focused
specialists is more productive once we
focus on one part of a process we are
apt to invent labor-saving devices
because it is in the best vehicle then
for innovation the free market economy
is the best form of economic system for
encouraging the technological project
finally the historical empirical
argument for the advantage of a free
market economy is the 1989 implosion of
his opposite the Soviet Union I was
there almost everywhere now in the world
it is admitted that a free market
economy is the most efficient method for
engaging in the
technological project now while private
property has always existed governments
from time immemorial have regulated and
controlled them in varying degrees to
advance their own purpose and not for
the technological project to get the
maximum advantage out of a market
economy it needs to be as free as
possible
to foster maximum innovation government
or the state can play a limited but
useful function by providing a legal
system for producing and protecting the
rights of individuals especially private
property for enforcing contracts and for
dispute resolution in order for a free
market economy to function it requires a
limited government known as a commercial
republic a republic is a government of
laws not of men a republic is not a
democracy for democracy involves
majority rule and not constitutional
rule from Plato and Aristotle right
through the 18th century American
Founding an important point democracy
was rejected as mob rule democracy
technically means majority rule and in
practice becomes a system of political
economy in which the bottom 51%
progressively loot the wealth and
productivity of the top 49% democracy
was understood by the American founders
as part of a system of checks and
balances that prevents one interests
from imposing its will upon the others
democracy as Madison made clear in many
of the Federalist Papers is a negative
device for blocking one powerful
interest group or faction from imposing
its will on others ma cracy was never
intended as a positive device for
articulating a suspect common good it
was during the 19th century in Europe
that democracy as majority rule was
posited as the will of the people
that is when Tocqueville and mill came
to view democracy as a threat as the
tyranny of the majority it evolved into
the formal notion that what is right is
what the majority sides or that the
common good is what the majority sides
it is on any given occasion now in the
post Renaissance and particularly
Reformation period Protestants
especially in America saw an important
connection between politics and
economics the desire for political
equality was not the desire to exercise
power for powers sake or certainly to
remake society on the contrary
Protestants were largely focused on
protecting the private sphere and the
spiritual dimension from political
corruption the connection between
politics and economics derived from the
fact that government controlled large
parts of the economy granting privileges
such as monopolies sin occurs land
grants other things political equality
implied economic equality in the sense
that all possessed the Liberty to pursue
God's work in this world not as an equal
distribution of the spoils part of the
meaning then of political equality was
equality before the law an equality
before the law meant appeal to the rule
of law and not the whim and the wishes
of any given political leader or faction
Cru sure to the development of the rule
of law in England and in America was the
theologian Richard Hooker who adopted
two mystic notions of natural law to the
Church of England and influenced John
Locke who quotes him extensively in the
second treatise now the demand for
equality before the law was an
expression of the notion of Christian
liberty
in rejecting a hierarchical conception
of the world Protestants could accept
that the political realm was no longer
subordinate to the religious realm but
at the same time the political realm had
to respect the traditional spiritual
realm of Christianity what we call
religious liberty that realm as
understood in Protestant terms meant the
opportunity to do God's work by
transforming the world economically
equality before the law came to mean
that there should be no legal barriers
to economic activity that did not apply
equally to everyone
placing legal barriers in the economic
realm was tantamount to thwarting God's
plan the rule of law has evolved
jurisprudentially into meaning a legal
system that constrains government
typically in practice the powers of
government and here we have lots of
government professors are divided among
separate branches with an independent
judiciary you're aware of that due
process and equal protection of the law
protects the rights of individuals by
constitutional means it is a system of
rules designed to allow individuals to
pursue their self-define interests
without interfering with that same
pursuit on the part of others the rule
of law provides the rules of the game
without determining the outcome of the
game now there is an important
connection between spiritual capital and
responsibility let me make that case
purpose refers to a person's belief that
life has meaning autonomy refers to a
person's belief that it is in his or her
power to fulfill that meaning through
his or her own acts creativity
ultimately comes down then to small
solitary acts in which an individual
conceives of something new something
innovative gives it a try without
knowing for sure how it will turn out
these streams then of accomplishment are
more calm
more extensive in cultures we're doing
new things and acting autonomously are
encouraged rather than disapproved in
order for a government to remain limited
and not become either authoritarian or
god forbid totalitarian or subject to
mob rule it is necessary that the
citizens of that government be special
kinds of people they must be autonomous
responsible people such people are those
who rule themselves ie they impose order
on their own lives through
self-discipline by exercising the
virtues in order to achieve goals that
they have set for themselves the
so-called Protestant work ethic I don't
think it's gone promoted the notions of
inner directed individuals an emphasis
on achievement through work equality
before the law and differentiation based
on the merits of achievement it is the
combination of the technological project
and free market economy that account for
the appearance of a new person a new
persona in our midst in America in
particular that person has a name
the entrepreneur in the 17th century we
find the first use of the term
entrepreneur from the French word on
strappin and a to undertake something
the entrepreneur discovers or imagine
new ways of combining resources to
create new products or new methods of
production the entrepreneur engages in
what Joseph Schumpeter was later to call
creative destruction autonomous people
practicing virtue our inner directed and
are therefore capable of participating
fully participating in the technological
project in creative and constructive
ways in fact the ultimate
I would argue of that project is not
simply to create wealth but to allow
autonomous people to express their
freedom and how such freedom reflects
God's will
wealth is a means to achievement and
freedom not an end in itself it is in
this sense that the technological
project is to be understood as what we
call the spiritual quest of modernity
this too is America's quest the ultimate
rationale for technological prowess is
not consumer satisfaction but the
production of the means of
accomplishment our greatest fulfillment
comes from freely imposing order on
ourselves in order to impose a creative
order on the world we have now come full
circle we started with the technological
project and we now have explained that
even the technological project itself is
an expression of spiritual capital the
judeo-christian roots of autonomy are
evident it is the culmination of the
Christian doctrine of free will and
responsibility transposed to the civil
sphere social scientists will offer some
resistance at this point those committed
to scientist some more some forms of
positivism make concede that religious
belief measurably has played some even
minor sig minorly significant role in
affecting market behavior and social
institutions in the past and present but
they normally and quite defensively
think that they ought not to have this
influence in the future my argument on
the contrary is that the spiritual
dimension is a necessary condition for
the continued vitality of free societies
any form of scientism is intellectually
deficient and scientists omit self
cannot generate an adequate account of
ethical principles autonomous people
want to run their own lives they do not
want government or any other
institutions to control them they are
jealous of their liberties and they want
the government to be restricted to its
proper sphere they are focused on taking
care of themselves and not looking out
and and not looking for others to take
care of them the abuse of democratic
procedure requires the political and
legal machinery of checks and balances
that our founders gave us political
machinery ultimately depends on a larger
cultural context we are therefore
brought back again to the need for a
culture that preserves something like
the importance of individuality and
human flourishing what we call spiritual
capital autonomous people want
recognition of this autonomy and they
want it and they get it from other
autonomous people who understand what
self discipline requires autonomous
people seek to promote autonomy and
others in order to encourage this
recognition they certainly believe in
helping others I won't deny that but
promoting the autonomy of others does
not mean redistribution it means
equality of opportunity not equality of
result it means holding everyone
accountable not condescension it means
when necessary teaching others how to
fish not giving them a fish autonomy is
not zero-sum the ultimate self-interest
of autonomous people is never in
conflict with the ultimate self-interest
of others in the ancient and medieval
world
there was no poverty problem almost
everyone was poor
and poverty was considered the natural
and unavoidable condition of the human
race now as a result of the
technological project and only in these
past three and a half centuries we have
now a situation where we can contemplate
a world of such abundance that no one or
few will be poor in the absolute sense a
world marked by ever-increasing growth
an opportunity it's a world they never
imagined what are the global
implications of the foregoing a national
government is obliged I think to serve
the market economy not only at home but
abroad one of the consequences therefore
of modern Commerce is the potential end
of war what caught referred to as
perpetual peace as Kant went on to argue
commercial Republic's do not go to war
with each other this hypothesis has
enormous empirical support it has been
argued that in the last 200 years since
Kant wrote perpetual peace there have
been no major Wars where all of the
combatants on both sides have been
commercial republics this leads to the
fore to the following tension and in a
sense paradox domestically the
government is to maintain a low profile
and a fairly passive supportive role for
commerce but in the international
context the government is to promote
activity and actively along the entire
panoply of the technological project
free market economies limited government
and the rule of law to intervene in
foreign affairs to bring about this
result is incumbent upon free
governments it is no use pretending that
the implications could be otherwise the
next American president whoever he I
could say she but it looks like he is
must abide by and within the established
heritage of America's long-established
spirit
capital he cannot deny it reject it or
pretend it away the democratic ideal of
interventionist socialism we have toyed
with surely must come to an end as it is
at odds with what we have defined as
America's true spiritual heritage
hopefully I've made the case that Amaris
America's success and leadership have an
integral relationship to its accumulated
spiritual capital and our heritage is
under assault from a variety of sources
today we therefore need to re identify
the unique content of America's
judeo-christian spiritual capital in
many ways this is what has essentially
come to define America in the process we
must also identify the origins and
sources of the current attacks on that
spiritual capital on judeo-christian
spiritual capital who are they what are
they they include most notably perennial
heretical utopian Gnosticism now in the
forms of socialism rizzo Marx derived
narratives of complaint about modernity
militant secularism which is certainly
on the rise and of course dangerously we
know militant radical Islam we must
rebut these attacks
indeed America I will argue
will not survive without a renewal of
its judeo-christian spiritual capital
specifically this means the importance
of personal autonomy and responsibility
stemming from the dignity of the human
being as a human person and the need to
support civil association with the
robust content full morality at no place
you'll notice did I advocate a theocracy
or anything less than a Democratic
Republic that is rooted in commerce and
ultimately produces human flourishing I
would however advocate the rejuvenation
of judeo-christian spiritual capital as
a cultural phenomenon the non apologetic
expression of one's faith the
re-education of misguided clerics
educators the media and America's
leaders and most of all direct honest
lawful and vigorous confrontation of
America's critics and its enemies
my friends tradition tells of a chime
that changed the entire world when it
rang on July 8 1776 it was the sound
from the Tower of Independence Hall
summoning the citizens of my hometown
and Nick's hometown something else we
have in common
Philadelphia to hear the first public
reading of the Declaration of
Independence by Colonel John Nixon now
the Pennsylvania Assembly had ordered
that Bell in 1751 to commemorate you
remember the 50th anniversary of William
Penn starter of Clifford's is which was
Pennsylvania's original constitutional
it spoke of the rights and freedoms
valued by people the world over
particularly insightful were Penn's
ideas on religious freedom his stance on
American rights and his inclusion of
citizens in enacting laws later that
same Liberty Bell gained iconic
importance when abolitionists in their
efforts to put an end to slavery
throughout America adopted it as a
symbol as the Bell was created to
commemorate the golden anniversary of
Penn's Charter the quotation and I quote
proclaim Liberty throughout all the land
unto all the inhabitants thereof taken
from Leviticus 25:10 seem particularly
apt I ask you in conclusion will you
join me in ringing that same bell again
to defend Andria articulate America's
spiritual capital
so I guess we have time for what
one question no Emily is my student I
get to go first
um it was an exciting lovely talk thank
you you're right I did like it
my question is the technological process
progress project that comes from the
word for art and art means making or
creating and there's a tendency in the
modern world for that project to turn
into the will to power comment a little
about that and what what what you find
ingrained in that project or inherent in
it that resists that tendency yes some
people on the left and the humanities
and at Yale I should say are quite
afraid of technology in the
technological project as we defined it
and I'm talking about our Nick and I are
talking about everything in the last 400
years which has a scientific basis that
has contributed to human betterment so
that certainly includes the arts but it
includes such sciences as medicine
advances in economics in law you know I
I guess you know my last name is
Scottish my grandfather was born in
Scotland I still belong to all the
Scottish clubs and associations the
modern world was largely invented during
50 years from 1750 to 1790 and Scottish
universities
not biased I didn't wear my kilt though
but whenever I hear the bagpipes I do
get a little emotional and that
technological project was really
invented there and then and spread its
wings over the course of the next
centuries and around the world and we
are the beneficiaries so while I say
yeah there's some cost associated with
certain technologies we actually see
that the cure to some of those things
they're actually present already in the
next evolution of those same
technologies so we have really
transformed the world we are a living
longer better more healthy more informed
my word system crashed the other night
and I wasn't sure that but more
technological lives than ever and
frankly you know our children are on a
trajectory that is even far beyond what
we've experienced we were joking the
other night I think some of us had
dinner about the cellphones we used to
have you know we'd carry them around
like this right now our little cell
phones are more powerful than all the
computing that sent the Apollo
astronauts into space and scary but true
so can we put that technology to good
use I hope and think so
part of the conversation earlier this
morning about 47% and distancing you
know ourselves from that I know
Governor Romney wondering sir if you
might comment on a little bit of the
brass tacks of recall tavae ting
judeo-christian spiritual capital what's
that look like relationally particularly
in thinking about Oz guinnesses phrase
not wolves at the door but termites in
the floor thinking about the internal
dynamics of the conversation this
morning what's that look like to recall
today judeo-christian spiritual capital
with their neighbors well that's that's
a very big topic an entire lectures
books indeed have been written on it I
wrote an earlier book called renewing
American culture and a lot of my work at
Yale revolves around this this question
and I think a lot of it begins frankly
in the places that you inhabit so I mean
to pay you a compliment to say that
American higher education and in
particular the liberal arts college and
in particular the church oriented or
somehow related to church background
colleges are the backbone of that
spiritual capital Yale and Harvard used
to be those do I have to remind you I
mean yeah was founded as a seminary for
congregations ministers it's gone a long
way from there our political spectrum at
Yale begins with Barack Obama on the
right
we had a celebration last year of Bill
Buckley's very famous now 60th
anniversary of Bill Buckley's got a man
at Yale and we turned out a large
audience but I jokingly say there still
is no God or mana you know
yeah so we have some work to do at the
core of our society and in every facet
of that society so we need to do that in
our families first of all but we have to
be faithful persons let's even proceed
that we have to exhibit the Spiritual
Exercises in our families we have to
practice those virtues in our mediating
institutions the father spoke about that
last night beautifully I'm a big
advocate of mediating structures the
schools are absolutely critical at every
level but we have to be willing to take
that argument into the public arena
because if we don't we will be as guilty
as the Christians were in Nazi Germany
because when they come to get you the
opportunity will already have been lost
so we have to defend religious liberty
first we have to re articulate these
great documents of the founding we have
a lot of our students don't know the
founders we have to teach them about the
founding that's a beginning place I
teach MBA students at Yale now I hope
this isn't on camera I guess it is I'd
be very careful most of my students
don't know what a virtue is they've
never heard the word virtue now they're
a little more familiar with the verb
because they read trashy novels and you
know listen to rap music and have
watched Miami Vice but have no clue of
what virtue is so we have work to do we
do have time for one final question
at the conclusion of the answer please
remain in your seats for an announcement
from the podium thank you my name is Jay
Cardella why before I ask you the
question I have to give a little bit of
background about myself my great
grandfather became a Christian in the
1870s I'm from India and typically we
were about to send man night brother
now I migrated to the United States in
1975 and I have attended the Baptist
Church as well as the Mennonite Brethren
churches when you were making certain
statements specifically about the
judeo-christian aspect of it are we
indirectly or directly leaning ourselves
into a state of theocracy you would
which you denounced but it still creates
doubts in the minds of the people if
that's the path we want to take is it
fair to all Christians who believe in
the saving knowledge of Jesus Christ
and the way they have been led to
salvation to be Christians I firmly
believe that saving knowledge has saved
me to be a Christian and to serve a
Christian institution but if you D mark
or delineate some section of the society
by using this specific that either you
fall in line with our thinking or you're
the enemy
yesterday this statement sir well I
certainly wouldn't want to categorize
different religious groups as enemies
and in fact my writing is quite the
opposite it has all to do with religious
liberty and that includes not only for
Jews or Christians but for every other
faith and actually for people who have
no faith at all and I would underscore
that two times three times if you look
at the work I've done at Yale I've gone
out of my way to write case studies on
companies that come not only from
Christian backgrounds but come out of
the Parsee faith in India out of Islam
from Hinduism and Buddhism so I actually
believe very strongly in religious
liberty and America as a country is a
place that has been a beacon on that
front that has allowed people to come to
these shores to experience that kind of
religious liberty and I would want to do
everything to maintain not only the
First Amendment but that experiment in
Liberty I don't think we can deviate
from that but we should also be aware
that secular humanism is a form of
spiritual content and it's one with
which we must do battle